would you say filmmaking has always been
easy for you I think writing comes
easier but then filmmaking because there
is also all the practical aspects you
know like funding getting a crew
together getting a producer I mean
that's that's always each film presents
its own challenges so I don't want to
say that oh it's so it's always easy to
make a film it's so easy to make a film
because it's you have to you know get
that Boulder up over the hill and each
time there's always a lot of effort and
it's a team effort but I think just
coming up with an idea for a film I that
I find relatively easy yeah in that
sense you think that goes back to like
you were saying earlier you love to be
sort of the receiver of the story and
and not the one pushing the story out
and and maybe you just got so good at I
don't know just absorbing stories yeah
maybe so now I all those stories and now
I can kind of put them out yeah maybe
you know III can agree with that too
because it is nice to just hear somebody
tell you about their day and believe me
there's a number of people that that's
all they want to do and sometimes it's
nice to just have that around I was just
wondering if if then it became just so
instinctual for you to to push out your
own stories just because you consumed so
many and also you know capturing you
know the nuances of you know language
that kind of stuff really fascinates me
and I think you can only really do that
if you listen very intently and growing
up in Portugal is going to the cinema
Plex part of just the normal teenage
lifestyle for sure and also we don't in
Portugal we don't really dub films
animation usually you know is dubbed
because especially you know for young
kids they obviously have to have to hear
it in Portuguese but you you always have
the option for any animator
film to see it in the original version
in Portugal so we don't we don't have
the kind of the dubbing practices that
for example exist in France or in Spain
where it's you know you're a bit more
hard-pressed to find the film in its
original version with English with own
Portuguese subtitles yeah do you
remember the first film or one of the
first films you saw as a teenager with
friends maybe at the cinema Plex
there was an American film and how that
affected you I think I think I saw kids
and kids definitely is such an such an
amazing film and it's and it's a film
that I think I mean it was it's like
lightning in a bottle and I think you
can only appreciate how much it really
was lightning in a bottle now when you
look at like you know the first time you
know rosario Dawson who was on camera
the first time the Chloe Chloe Sevigny
was was on camera and then it's just the
amazing turns from the non actors I
think it was the first time that that
you know the kid who paid played telly
had acted before and just watching that
film in seeing you know what could be
done if you really embraced that that
indie spirit you don't need a lot of
money to make a good film you really
don't you just have to be very very
smart and very receptive to what you
know the people that you want to work
with can give you and when you were
watching those movies was that and what
inspired you to want to go to school in
London and then UCLA or what was that
well I mean I I for a long time I
thought I was I would be a video artist
so I was kind of looking more like you
know people Oh dearest I'm his you know
very very famous Swiss video artist
looking at other female video more like
experimental filmmakers that was kind of
the path that I thought I was going to
take but then once I left art school and
I started working as a camera assistant
I think that's when I was really I
really was intrigued about maybe one day
directing something that was more
narrative perhaps you know more
more commercial but still Indy because I
saw that it was very rare to work with
you know a female director or female DP
or if you must screenwriter and I wanted
to be part of the change that I wanted
to see like sort of like Cindy Sherman
Cindy Sherman as well of course big
reference right and how it G was most
often right the focus of what she did so
she didn't even need a crew but yeah and
just that interesting sort of the
selfies before selfie culture exactly
and kind of deconstructing you know what
it is to be a woman because I mean only
only a woman can answer that question
but it was but how many times have women
being muses right we're the thing that
is is looked at and we don't really
maybe get the opportunity to look at
ourselves especially in like in a
creative artistic way and so it's a it
was absolutely very important like Cindy
Sherman the guerrilla girls as well what
they did was I mean it's revolutionary
it's inspiring makes you think you know
I want to be like that when I grow up
you know and so how did you do it did
you apply for just the one school in
London or did you apply to others and
what was the process I applied I applied
for a few I applied to the rival well
back then it was the rival I don't know
if it still is which was Goldsmith's so
that was like all the way on the other
side of London but in the end I didn't
get into Goldsmith's but I got into the
Slade and I also got into like Central
Saint Martins and and Wimbledon as well
and London College of Communication but
in the end I thought the Slade was was
the best fit for me and so you got your
bachelor's and then decided you would go
to UCLA after that or how did that
what's so I mean I'm quite long in the
tooth so I did my undergraduate degree
what does a camera assistant got some
funding in Portugal made my first short
film there and I filmed that in 2012 and
then I did a few more short films in
Portugal I was there for a while I
realized that if I really wanted to have
a career as an indie filmmaker that I
was
you know better off leaving because
Portugal still has like a very small
film industry and then that's when I
applied for UCLA and then I started the
master's there in 2015 yeah what was
your first assignment for this UCLA
screenwriting program so I was in the
the name of the program is production
slash directing MFA and they I mean they
encourage their well really they they
want their directors to write even
though there is an a screenwriting
department which is you know very
prestigious at UCLA Bowie's directors we
we had to write and I think it must have
been one of the first assignments that
we had we had to write a script for just
a two-minute film just like a little
tiny it's a bit of a glorified film
exercise but that was maybe one of the
first things we had to do like year 1 oh
wow two-minute film just a two minute
yeah and it has a three act structure to
it not really but what I think they try
and teach you is that I think you only
have four hours to shoot it and they
only give you one card so I think that
the the purpose of the exercise is to is
to teach you economy with timing is
absolutely very important on a film set
there's a directive being able to make
you know fast decisions and so what was
your two minute project about so that I
mean that is on my website for free oh
there um what's the domain looks like
what's its called 88 and at that point I
had already been in contact with Kwan
Reynoso who who's one of my friends and
he's a teacher at Compton high school
and he's also a professional actor and I
had asked him you know how are any of
your kids like interested in acting and
he said yes and so he introduced me to
two John weddington who was one of his
students at the time and he is the star
of 88 and he basically he goes in for a
casting audition and is kind of
dismissed by the casting directors but
then kind of like you know proves his
worth to them in the space of like two
minutes mm-hmm yeah yeah because you
know maybe this is jumping ahead but I
found it interesting that you said that
a lot of the people that a lot of the
students that grow up in Compton that
they don't say that they're from Compton
when they go to job interviews they say
South Central very interesting because
they feel that it's a bias against and
also I mean and that's something that
for example in in Lisbon exists as well
the kind of you know in neighborhoods
that have a bit of a stigma yes I know
about that right people associate that
particular suburb in Lisbon with you
know crime and poverty and all these
like very negative things and so those
those kids also when they're going to
job interviews they don't they don't say
they're from Baraka they say they're
from in the daughter which is kind of
like the equivalent of not saying you're
from Compton saying you're from South
Central yeah very interesting
yeah even here in LA I know applying for
a job years ago and they said to me why
do you live there and I was so shocked
you know and I thought other people do
it it's an interesting thing and I just
swore that I was not going to to cave in
to that but I almost wonder if it'd have
been easier so that's very fascinating
when when I read that it really like
triggered a lot in me that you know you
had said that because we're where I was
referring to you was not considered
there's not a statement as other areas
but and did you focus on that in the
film did you talk about that when you
finally did your feature did you explore
this so the feature kind of talks a bit
more about the the stigma of having of
you know being daca eligible or TPS
eligible and having that status
potentially revoked and then becoming
undocumented which you know is is a
status in and of itself so it kind of
talks more about that than about you
know just generally Compton per se right
okay and when were you planning
when did you already started writing
this film was this before 2016
no I started writing the script for
lanlan negra I think at the end of 2017
like maybe October November I think I
had like the first act Yeah right I know
I'm jumping ahead here sorry but I was
just I was just curious about the timing
so that was how you sort of got your
foot in the door with Compton high
school was in doing the two-minute to go
back to that and I'm sorry I'm jumping
around but yeah okay so interesting so
you kind of already knew the world a
little bit maybe they trusted you and
you were able to go in and meet some of
the students yeah so that's kind of
where it started but then I did another
short film again in Compton with mr.
Renault so where he played a cop and and
so I'd done a few films and with Compton
non-actors and then that eventually led
to the feature
you